Benedicto 16 yace debajo de la Basílica
de San Pedro tal como era su deseo el
papa emérito fue sepultado en las
antiguas criptas donde permaneció Juan
Pablo II el ex líder de la Iglesia
Católica recibió una última despedida
celebrada por el Papa Francisco con
melones del bannchero hemos venido con
la fragancia de la gratitud y el bálsamo
o la esperanza para mostrarle una vez
más el amor que es eterno queremos
hacerlo con la misma sabiduría ternura y
devoción que él nos derramó a lo largo
de los años juntos queremos decir padre
en tus manos encomendamos su espíritu
la jornada contó con la presencia del
canciller alemán olafones entre la
delegación alemana
además en la plaza de San Pedro decenas
de miles de dolientes se congregaron
para el último adiós
Fue una ceremonia hermosa no conocí
personalmente al papa pero he leído algo
escrito por él en el pasado
una ceremonia histórica eso es lo que
voy a recordar era importante para mí
estar aquí decir okay Estuve allí
participé no es una ceremonia que se ve
todos los días el aspecto extremadamente
raro de ver un Papa enterrando a otro Es
realmente un evento único en la historia
alrededor de 200.000 personas estuvieron
en los cinco días de exequias de
Benedicto 16 también más de 4.500
miembros de la Iglesia Católica y
delegaciones de más de 20 países
formaron parte del cierre de una era
histórica en el Vaticano la era de los
dos papas